yes it does because there's there's
thousands of legal immigrants that are
trying to get in this country through
what are called h-1b visas that are
skilled and especially technology that
are not allowed in we have a broken
immigration system not on not just on
the illegal immigration side but also
dealing with legal immigration dealing
with those that are trying to get here
legally that have applied for years that
legitimately should be part of
technology and computers and are not
allowed in because of a huge backlog
because inefficiency in our bureaucratic
system because they don't have enough
staffing at the Immigration Service what
we need to realize is that we can't just
deal with illegal immigration we have to
deal with legal immigration and what I
would do is I mentioned all those
standards for illegal immigrants first
to be able to come into America should
be those that are trying to get here
legally and those that are here legally
trying to become citizens
you